rebecca bonsoir vous ajoutez votre voix
à aux nombreuses voix qui ont commenté
cet album de coldplay depuis quelques
jours au jour des imams et oui oui pour
des contres les uns des plus grands
groupes du monde
ça fait 14 ans déjà depuis merlot succès
que les a consacrés qui contrôleront des
hymnes un bien beau spectacle toujours
exaltant c'est patrick geenens spectacle
je faisais jamais vous coûtera alors
leurs ports c'est différent c'est un
album qui s'intitule ghost stories et
c'est un album qui hantent et on
pourrait le dire quand le fantôme de
goût ni de parcours ce support à celle
lancée par oui c'est ça chris martin le
chanteur se séparent des boulonnais trop
beau et ça c'est vraiment un bel album
dès la rupture c'est chez de le dire
mais sexy on écoute
très pas répondre oui cette chanson là
où est cette chanson je pense que est
une esquisse de de la grandeur de
combler mais sur cet album c'est comme
si complet avec plus vraiment envie
d'être comme tous les deux se dissocier
de sa marque de commerce
ce sont des experts dans milan colis en
chagrin mais où avant il y avait lumière
et espoirs il n'ya que désormais
obscurité et des connexions je pense que
vraiment on ne ruine c'est vraiment un
album qui me fait mal et c'est
minimaliste et c'est parfois très
étrange des phares sans vraiment
comprendre voie maltée une
particulièrement dit de risque faisant
partie de l'accord
non
c
à
voilà qu'on paie ghost stories c'est pas
nécessairement l'album qui va passer à
l'histoire
mais si vous pouvez les attraper en
spectacle pour que l'on passe qui
viennent soit sur n'importe quoi
oui marie mais j'ai des populaires hyper
populaire comme des petits pains chauds
mordacq d'abord cet album s'intitule mc
son cinquième en dix ans qu'il est sorti
une semaine déjà
dix neuf mille exemplaires vendus qui
d'autre au québec peut faire c'est un
phénomène mari mais c'est probablement
la plus belle réussite de star académie
c'est lt même pas la dernière
du coup on me connaissent et sont bio
avec google pour attirer ou garder delà
des excuses et a fait quelque chose
ensemble ils ont tellement aimé cette
collaboration sont justement
d'immortaliser une autre sur disque
mais coût du repas
les corps j'ai maintenant denaisis
souffrir
mais quand tu devras
le jeu
celle de toi
donc j'avais aimé l'album oui moi je
trouve que marine et on peut passer à
côté de marine
honnêtement c'est une fille qui est une
bosseuse c'est une fille déterminée
ambitieuse qui a fait comme je le dis de
cinq albums en dix ans devait faire une
compilation elle était trop trop inspiré
et une douzaine de fois le centre bell
et sur cet album là il ya quand même des
belles surprises
un peu de margon boss l'essai avec
conscience pour moi soir